hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to KC animatronics now
I haven't played this in a while because
things got away from me but I don't
think I can stand here too long to make
an introduction about it I got to get
over here and I got to figure out how to
get batteries into this goddamn radio
if this even is the radio that I'm
supposed to do and I don't even know if
that's what I'm supposed to do I was a
little confused because the mechanics of
the owl didn't seem to be very clear to
me and I don't know if that's just me
being dumb which is a very big
possibility and generally speaking about
everything that I'm doing around this
world where did he go where did he go
why is my ah batteries that might be
something that I need okay
animatronics attack their own I
shouldn't be here reading this you guys
can read and I gotta get going because
death is upon me and I have batteries
and I need to get them to the radio oh
boy
okay I don't hear Wolfie stem stomping
around okay how do I know is that what I
wanted what is that thought that dyad a
group leader has given us a task every
mum must draw an unusual object or
character for Halloween she said that
she wanted her group to participate in
an exhibit like no other okay but I'm
still could boo is that a code wait no
that's just some writing on that well
I'm a little confused I don't know why
everything's still blurry because it
seems like the tempo no the
temperature's going up why is the
temperature going up that's a good
question
I've new okay so I'm in trouble
that's what oh I'm in trouble okay okay
alright don't know what that was but I
recognize it as a bad sound and I can't
have completely forgotten how to play
since then I could have sworn that was
like the only I was like the only option
for
hi okay that was like the only option
for radio right at least that's my
assumption was I don't know where else
there would be a radio I've never even
seen a radio I don't even know what a
radio is [ __ ] ah that uh that uh see
it wasn't exactly the noise it made
who's just suddenly there was a wolf
there and I didn't hear any step step
and so I have no idea why that was that
thing that that was but okay so I'm
guessing he's just sitting there because
he's guarding something
and then owl boy over there is guarding
that so use the battery pack to turn on
the radio again I don't know exactly
where the radio is if this isn't it so
there must be like a handheld radio
somewhere else in here which I can only
imagine means always still there oh
that's lovely a delightful maybe he's
gonna go the room mm-hmm who don't have
good okay so obviously this radio is
okay that's how you're gonna be you sack
of [ __ ] okay all right then
Wow alright so he I don't know how or
why he got me that didn't make much
sense at all how did he go away before
but now all the sudden he's seen big
giant douche me mmm stupid oh he's gone
don't know why but he is gone my
flashlights about to run out of battery
okay so grab the battery packs so the
radio that they're talking about has to
be in the back area hey who did where
why are you in there
ooh he's in there isn't he okay that's
why that happened but I should be
alright all things consider oh hey okay
this does not help this does not help me
oh because I'm turning my back to wolfy
you that is oh no oh no oh no oh no in
the closet I don't know if it's gonna
help this is not gonna help this so not
gonna help so not gonna help maybe maybe
if I look at uh d1 d1 d1 oh yeah I
thought it was on d1 it didn't make any
sense okay it's gotta be something like
back in the warehouse okay
he said top it okay I think he's if
topped away he's definitely standing
there he's camping there like an [ __ ]
all that hiding for nothing try to hide
better try to screw you better oh hi oh
oh oh
open open closed closed closed hey he's
there he's just lurking there
he is he totally is he's just standing
there
only to get you if you go around that
corner so so that's like so that's like
closed off do you get around him you
just gotta lose him
it's the only thing I can think of and
I'm about to die anything whoa wait I
was open what it was open what the [ __ ]
are you kidding me
what
okay so I guess he's moved now it's
pretty good okay would you so just don't
get caught okay okay okay
I think I'm clear am i clear
whoa-oh lock pick oh Jesus oh jeez oh
good and there's a radio in here please
let there be a radio in here please let
there be a radio in here
I was right there I didn't even know
about that where is it oh that's so
minut that's so incredibly my new okay
that's not good all right we're own Oh
Oh No
hello hi can you check one bag dawn
bishop and you play by the rules I can't
let you get away with the files okay you
know this reminds me of my cat Emma I
miss her okay I made that bastard scream
and cry but it didn't make me calm and
then I realized that I must punish you
for what you've done it is a pity that
my toys are not good enough though we
might be able to increase the power a
bit goodbye bishop it was fun playing
with you
okay so what I'm spoke
[Music]
oh okay I still don't know about the
radio thing but apparently I got some
files and apparently there's a key card
on the back of one of the animatronics
and I'm gonna guess that it's the owl
cuz he's the only one that you would be
able to get around I suppose man it's
gonna be challenging challenging okay so
what happened did something break out of
the thing that was in here it better
have given me a checkpoint because if it
didn't I'm gonna be very reboost also
it's very dark it's darker than it used
to be and also everything seems
everything seems to be going black so
what I got to do is up oh it's still in
there okay
so that's good maybe that is good so
that means that what I really hope that
saved it better have saved so I got to
get a keycard from the back of one of
the animatronics thinking the owl hey
friend
oh are you docile what huh oh I can't
see anything
hi okay I got you I got you God like
it's the keycard for some door here
you're awfully calm for being presented
with such a conundrum so where was there
another door with a key card in it that
I have not opened yet I don't remember
so what were there any other doors I
don't know hey buddy how you doing I
don't remember there being another door
huh oh maybe wasn't there one towards
like on the other side of the metal
fence there was another door with a key
card man is so hard to see
hmm it was another door like on the
other side of this one
I had a keycard maybe is that it I don't
know
that's closed wouldn't been anything
else back here would it been maybe to
unleash the beast that's in the box box
of Beast the Beast box no can't even
pick that it looks like I'm stuck
there's no other door that damn it I
can't see anything
god damn it why is it what I'm dying I'm
dying aren't I this is me dying from
suffocation
what the hell what what what what hi
okay what where's it gonna send me back
okay Elise is here I'm still confused oh
well hi
okay that was inconvenient for me you
see how you got that that [ __ ] me no
okay ah ah I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
I went the wrong way what what happened
to my golden opportunity of them being
all deactivated is that just not a thing
anymore am I just I have to deal with
this now
yeah I I think I gotta just deal with it
this is this is not cool
oh well you don't have it anymore what
but I don't have it you don't have it
and I don't have it we don't have it and
what's going on
I am so confused Oh oh you have it now
looks like it's the key card for some
door so I don't know which door damn the
card isn't compatible with that door no
it's not is it it wouldn't be that easy
and also everything of going dark again
they're gonna power back up and then
Nimmo my buttcheeks just kill me just
kill me kill me okay I am utterly
confused as to what to do and also I'm
like physically ill I can't keep doing
this because the vision with the the
thing going on did I get a code at any
time I don't remember and there's no
note system so how would I even know
there isn't a note says I'm not just
talking on my ass about that there's not
a note system so how am i there's like
no journal there's no reflection there's
just a tablet and everything that you've
got on your person and he's gonna eat me
because apparently that's the curse that
please man
ah man huh so either way that's all I'm
gonna do for now and then I'm gonna try
to finish this up in just one more
episode again sorry for the delay I
wanted to get to the sooner but life
gets in the way sometimes so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what I'm supposed to do or how to
solve the what what's the code how do I
not die I don't know I'll figure it out
so thank you everybody again and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye-bye